a Las Vegas family is searching for
answers after their 18 year old son
unexpectedly collapsed in school last
week it happened January 3rd at amplus
Academy that's near Durango and sunset
in Spring Valley the teen passed away
Sunday Joshua baguerra Joins us live in
the studio after speaking with the
family Joshua now Jordan Bristol's
family says he was a selfless caring
person and even in his death that Legacy
of thinking of others continues as
barista's organs were donated to help
those in need
Jordan's mom says his teachers at amplus
describe the high school senior as a
southern gentleman the Bristol family
moved from Central Louisiana to Las
Vegas nearly two years ago his family
says Jordan collapsed Tuesday in the
bathroom of his school it was about 25
minutes before someone found him his
family doesn't know what happened other
than his heart stopped they say he
doesn't have any medical history and say
he doesn't do any drugs in a statement
to 8 news now amplist says Jordan
experienced a cardiac arrest at school
and staff provided him with medical
attention until paramedics arrived he
was then transported to Southern Hills
Hospital Jordan was kept in the ICU
until Sunday so his organs could be
harvested the school says quote the
atlas Community sends our love and
condolences to the Bristol family as
well as to all of Jordan's family
friends and acquaintances and quote
Jordan was planning to join the military
after graduating from high school in a
GoFundMe page created to help pay for
brista's funeral to post says no amount
of money can take away the hurt the
family is going through but they hope
the funds will allow Jordan to have the
resting place he deserves
now amplus academy has several
therapists social workers and sort of
and uh excuse me counselors to support
staff and students as they grieve
Kirsten